podcast
special guest my guy jesse what's up kev
jesse is here
uh man um well let's shout out your
let's kick things off
first of all how you been bro good man
been busy we just did a uh
we tried to do a prank yeah i had eric
bellinger and hitmaker up here and we
and we tried to do a prank and uh
it just didn't end how we had
anticipated no they're not very happy
with it
no disrespect it was funny but it was
like yeah
i hate when people are like not happy
after so
how often does that happen like because
i know i'll notice like sometimes you'll
be able to show people's faces in some
of these videos and a lot of them like
i'm assuming if someone's face is
blurred
yeah then that means that they didn't
yeah they didn't get like consent to
like
do it normally like we feel like it's
risky like they'll get flagged the video
down and you have to
for the most part you got to get consent
from anybody who's in the videos
we should we don't do it a lot but um
yeah it's more when we're like oh this
dude's pissed or like
i don't know like we feel like it's
risky at all we could jeopardize a whole
video that took like
has there ever grand i was gonna say has
there ever been like i know there's
times where you guys
have trolled like trump supporters to
say some crazy ass [ __ ]
yeah has there ever been a time where
something came out and
you guys got hit with a lawsuit later or
anything like that
no dude we can we've been lucky i think
we're like
to be dead honest we need to like watch
that though because we're big now so
like
if we if you we shoot a video like that
guy's gonna see it you know i mean
right right right right not that size so
so should i on that
um for anybody who don't know jesse is a
part of the elk boys
og member it was you and kyle right
originally yeah wasn't there a third guy
originally there lucas
what's he doing kicking himself in the
ass no he's uh he's plumbing he's happy
he's a plumber yeah he got into trades
and um
he's uh he's back in canada i still i
still hit him up sometimes i go
snowboarding or something
so now boys are the hottest [ __ ] on
youtube
one of the hottest clothing would you
call it a clothing line
yeah i mean sorry it's like started out
as merch but it's i think it's a brand
it's yeah um full send um
and you guys do you know some of the
craziest funniest [ __ ]
so i feel like at some point in time
everyone's seen one of your guys's
pranks yeah probably um and
you you know we're doing these prank
videos and recently you kind of stepped
away and we're missing in a lot of
episodes
and i know that you named your first
video on [ __ ] which we'll get to
uh why you're not filming anymore but i
really don't think you said why you
weren't filming anymore it was more like
a little clickbaity yeah it was a little
clickbaity so why what
why are you no longer i was saving it
for this interview okay so yeah so
it kind of explained you know why you're
not in the videos anymore like like
we're used to seeing you
um basically just uh
took a step back i obviously i've been
drinking for having sober for like six
or seven months now
congrats yeah and i feel great doing
that and just the
steady on the road steady partying
steady all that [ __ ] getting arrested
[ __ ]
it just i mean i've been doing this [ __ ]
for seven years so it was a while
and uh but obviously it's our job it's
our company so um
just basically took a not a break but
came back to
really do what i want to be doing which
is the clothing and organizing that
and honestly a week of doing it and
knowing how much of an asset i am in
that field and
other parts like other like parts of the
business
i was just like yeah like this makes
sense so
kyle's kind of taking on the milk
channel i'm back doing
all like merch photo shoots
marketing all that planned designing and
um
and now like what we're getting into now
which i was gonna tell you about is the
what we're doing with sen club and
trying to make like a competitive
platform against like hulu or netflix
eventually but
starting like all originals and we got a
warehouse down in newport that we're
probably approving for is on the 15th
nice like 14 000 square feet and um
we're gonna put a bunch of like sets in
there
and we're we're signing comedians wow so
that's what i was gonna say like you you
mentioned
um the send club that's something that
exists now i kind of looked at it as
like your guys's version of only fans or
patreon
yeah yeah i start off that way but i i
want to evolve it into like
its own thing yeah it's like there's
netflix there's hulu
there's send clip like i mean the way i
see it is like
what mtv used to be like it was all
reality it was like
college audience high school audience
like our same audience and uh
i think no one there's not really a
platform like an internet-based platform
where you can subscribe to that's like
that right right and i
kind of want to just bring that back
like there's we have a like a shitload
of show ideas written out
and like i just yeah there's so much
potential there to grow
um okay so the clothing line is its own
monster
you guys will do a draw how often do you
do a job is it once a month uh every
like two or three months
so you guys will do a drop and it's a
year you guys like track all the [ __ ]
views going on worldwide like what has
been the
most like your biggest day like you're
like like
monetarily without getting your pockets
like let's say like
your biggest day one day sales on the
site because
it's it's crazy we had like 350
000 people with their credit card on our
website at once
jesus christ i don't really think
there's
much people in the streetwear game that
are like really touching those numbers
like supreme maybe
i don't even think so i mean yeah the
other day yeah sure but no
that's not so dope it's just yeah it's
it's insane the amount of traffic we get
so 350 000 people ready to buy something
at the same time
that's why everything sells out because
who the [ __ ] printing 350th yeah yeah
seconds that's crazy
damn is it because i know you guys ended
up getting um
like you can't monetize your videos
right yeah we make like
nothing off i've never even seen a
youtube check personally i don't even
know what bank kind of goes into
so whose idea was it because you guys
are smart man because i feel like
there's a lot of people who haven't
like really nobody i can think of who's
done as good of a job and making
your brand like a lifestyle like the
clothes
and just everything your guys are slang
is caught on
you know like whose idea was it to start
making it
more of like a lifestyle thing and
bringing in the clothing and
because i feel like it's it's unique
not a lot of people have decided to kind
of you know
make it a full a full experience like
you guys have outside of just the videos
um
it's it's mutual for sure i think um
me and kyle both like have we both have
a different side of each company
and uh us just coming together like just
kind of made magic
also tying in like just kind of like
striking gold
i think a little bit it takes that too
it takes hard work takes division but it
takes like
it there's a little bit of luck in there
too i mean like the fact that full send
just took off bigger than us is like
insane and uh we just helped you know
get it there right right right put some
gas on it but
yeah so right now like all the money is
essentially coming from
the clothing [ __ ] yeah because there's
really no youtube revenue coming in
right now like it's funding but i still
look at it as like
there's um the clothing is like funding
all the other projects we want to start
it's like it's watering all those
flowers you know what i mean so like
i still think that one day the and i've
talked to kyle about this and he agrees
it's the the clothing is going to be
even small on the scale of what we want
to do and like where revenues are going
to be coming in
like yeah because i feel like i've seen
so many people who were dope at like
creating content and then they end up
getting burnt out or they're just like
you know the the [ __ ] stops being funny
like when when you guys come up with
like i mean lately the stuff you haven't
been a part of has been kind of
crazy like going out of the country and
yeah
that [ __ ] is crazy um who's
their new season they just did is like
nuts i was watching some of the footage
back and i was like
do you like miss like were you like [ __ ]
i wish i was there or was it kind of
like
you've been there done that yeah like
i've been there done it but like it is
nice to be
like obviously with all the guys doing
all that it's just um
i was finding myself too much like i'm
at a club or i'm i'm in an airbnb
or i'm i'm i'm just sitting here like
kind of like
[ __ ] i know there's so much more i
could be doing with my time like within
this company like
and i think it's just the second i like
started diving into like
i've always been involved in like the
clothing but like once i could really
dive in i was like damn like this is
like like i don't have a day off anymore
it's like
my time just feels i don't it made me
happy because i wasn't that happy and
just like that my happiness came from
feeling like an asset again what made
you want to stop drinking
um i guess a mixture of like getting fit
getting healthy for one but also just
like
um anxiety and like [ __ ] depression
everything it smiles everything out of
control so like and then i don't know if
it was becoming an issue or
like it's kind of your guys's brand too
right it's like if you if you're out
with the guys it's like
oh yeah every fan you meet's like chug
this beer take this shot
[ __ ] it's like the way i look at it
too is like if i'm quitting drinking for
a bit
it's not serious but like if you're
quitting heroin you don't go hang out
with a bunch of
people doing heroin you know i mean like
you you gotta go
change people you surround yourself with
and that's pretty much
another part that i just did just like
might as well surround myself with
people
and things that are like positive for
where i'm like mentally going
i wanted to ask you um because you and i
have talked you're not like a political
guy at all
right you guys
over the last you know six seven months
with all the election [ __ ] you guys had
your your run of trolling trump
supporters and then
um the trump thing happens
where the guys get pulled up on stage
like you weren't in that video you
weren't there but i feel like there's
like
um there might be a misconception and
obviously not with steve but like that
you guys are like
heavily on the political side when it
comes to that [ __ ] because i know you
know
when it comes to anything you guys have
a fan base that are probably on both
sides of the [ __ ] fence you know what
i'm saying yeah
but i want to you you weren't there so
it was like that's something
like did you know that was going to
happen because that's a big i mean look
whether or not you [ __ ] with trump or
not
that's kind of crazy to be on air force
it looks like i didn't go
because of like the trump thing probably
but honestly it was it was the time the
guys went up to
um dubai to do fight island with the ufc
yeah
and uh i was flying into vegas to
quarantine to
go do that and um i ended up
i was on a plane with one of our filmers
who
had coveted or like got positive for it
so just because i was on the same plane
as him i wasn't even sitting next to him
but
it was contact so i couldn't go and then
so i'd
i'd drive from vegas all the way down to
cali stay in an airbnb for two weeks and
then
it overlapped onto the trump thing so i
couldn't do that
and uh and that's kind of all what
spiraled this like i'm quarantining
anyway so i started just working on like
other [ __ ] other [ __ ] and started
finding like like
yeah a lot of work there and um but yeah
that was kind of what spiraled
a lot of things i think in right in that
direction but
yeah but when it comes to the trump
thing and all that [ __ ] like i said i i
literally don't give a [ __ ] about
politics like one bit like
i feel like yeah you and kyle like dudes
from canada who get free health care and
you know
yeah we're just like like just it's a
joke right i got an opportunity to [ __ ]
around with like some trump [ __ ] for a
title like you're gonna do it like
that what's the um like the closest
the most scared you've ever been filming
um i'm scared i mean
i'd probably say the the incident in
ohio when uh like there was like a
helicopter there was like
six different counties the police showed
up they go swat showed like it was like
sketchy what was the prank i was uh
wearing like a white jumpsuit with a
shovel and like covered in fake blood
like i remember that one i was in like a
bookstore
asking for like where's the dummy
where's the how to clean up a body for
dummies book like section like acting
like i'm like
i need knowledge on how to clean up a
body right someone took it seriously
called the cops and uh
yeah just got arrested and spent like
a day and a half or something in jail
what was i i don't understand what were
the charges like
um it's a it's like an inducing panic um
like a charge yeah i found that found
out about that one i know it was a
charge either
but uh it was like two first degrees
they were trying to push and then
they were pushing for like six months
and and that was the most that's what
struck a lot of this [ __ ] was that i was
i had to go back to canada because i had
to and i'm awaiting this trial for nine
months
and they don't know that like at this
point we don't know i'm getting off or
whatever's happening they're just
telling me like yeah we might be able to
get down to three months or like
whatever like
and uh shut up brad koffel a lawyer he
[ __ ] saved my ass but um
you're looking at real jail time i mean
i don't i didn't know right
i think it was the nine month just like
not knowing that i could just go to that
trial and be like oh i'm actually gonna
go sit in jail now right
and i just yeah it was not good
didn't like it yeah because that what
was that was that two years ago
i think so yeah yeah a while ago now and
then what yeah
it's crazy too because you guys never
stopped like covet start like started
and you guys just never [ __ ] stopped
you guys were just going to like the
ozarks and like
was was that like was it a hard decision
to be like look guys we're just going to
push through this and just go where it's
where it's like it's weird because our
company wasn't really affected by coven
like however a lot of companies it's sad
that got affected by it and uh
it's honestly more people were watching
videos so our views because they're at
home more
more people like aren't shopping in
malls and stuff so like our merch jobs
do better
um the hardest thing that would be
affected is possibly just filming
like pranks just aren't as funny when
you're wearing a face mask and the
person you're pranking you can't see
their facial expression
so i think that was the biggest way that
we took like an l but
no we just had to push through keep
doing it um
so you just launched the show [ __ ]
which is kind of your
um it's on the full send channel yeah so
it's like an example of like what i'm
talking about making like our own
original content
so we're testing the waters on the full
send channel which is
basically going to be like a complex
just like bunch of different shows
different people signed starting their
own shows writing shows
like all that and uh and [ __ ] was
it was just an idea i had that like when
i started doing all the [ __ ] behind the
scenes and i was like
i remember being a kid and being like
[ __ ] like like i still get excited about
this [ __ ] like
that i could buy this shirt and like cut
and sew it and [ __ ]
measure it all out and like like
anything is possible if you want to
change the button to say like full set
if you want to do
anything like we have those tools now we
have the like
the the money to do it so and i just i
think that showing that to the
kids that are like also being
entrepreneurial and want to start a
clothing brand or
anything business related just like kind
of thought it would be cool to
show behind the scenes and um push kids
in that direction
yeah you said something on one of the
episodes about how you whatever per
like you try to run a business through
whatever big purchase you make to kind
of pay for it
because you got that g wagon um and
you're doing like car
you're doing you're doing car auction
[ __ ] yeah like i mean it was just a
connect so i just
i made a story i was like um like
like i mean like if i'm gonna go buy a g
wagon i'm like
well i'm gonna first find the best way
to get it so i get the best deal so i
first found a guy that does car auctions
and this is and then so i was like oh
well like we started talking a little
bit i don't have to really do any work
he's just like i'll flip some cars give
me some capital
and then it just created itself into a
little business and flipped like
you know like a dozen cars every week
and uh
built up enough money got paid off the g
wagon in like a couple months is like
pretty crazy but yeah just it just bugs
me to spend money i mean that's why i
don't got any jewelry
no we were talking yesterday like how
some like there was times where you guys
flew private and you were like yo just
i'm gonna take a regular flight
yeah i just [ __ ] i don't know what it
is i'm just
i mean i grew up pretty [ __ ] poor so
it's probably that but just like
i'm not cheap i'm just not like as i am
that's always gonna i'm just trying i'm
going after that vision and just
being set for life so uh how originally
did you and kyle link up like what was
like your guys's origins of like meeting
um like how we met yeah uh that was
i had an mtv show when i was younger and
uh kyle started the channel at about
like 20 or 30 000 subscribers and uh
my show was done and i was like looking
for youtube type stuff so i posted on
facebook like
i was just i was like looking at ads i
was trying to get involved in something
and
and someone a fan of my show and a fan
of nelk
like reached out and connected me and
kyle so you should reach out to these
guys so i pitched him like
a few prank ideas i could do and [ __ ]
and he's like yeah let's run them so we
went and filmed and
i think it was like the prank went out
great and a couple weeks later we moved
to la together
you guys are um like from the same area
of canada we're about like like i was
living in hamilton at the time
so it's like in 45 minutes away from
mississauga where they grew up
but i grew up like maybe an hour and a
half was that 20 that was 2016.
are you guys originally linked up what
year was that
i'm so bad with dates i know it was like
six to seven years ago okay so
you know it's crazy yeah and then like
you know
being i know that with any any sort of
you know especially in music you see
like
any sort of group or you know there's
always going to be conflict do you guys
do you guys ever butt heads on the
vision of of where things are going
yeah i think so yeah i think it's it's
all normal though you're gonna do this
yeah of course like we
we're both completely different guys and
we're both grew up differently so i
think like
you're always gonna like [ __ ] have
different visions or have different
opinions on how to do things and uh
but yeah that's all part of the process
i mean i think anyone who wants a
company or someone is
gonna deal with that what uh where did
you guys find steve at
steve kyle actually found steve he uh
he was like just like i think he was
chugging just like bottles or something
and he had like 500 followers on
instagram or something like that just
chugging [ __ ]
just chugging [ __ ] and kyle's like no
trust me this guy's gonna be [ __ ]
dope so we
bring him down to la and it was like
crazy
like that was like that was like a first
like
damn like we have some power to like
like we should be a management company
like we can
like we should be signing people because
it was like
he had 500 followers and then i think
it's like a month in la and he like
his youtube channel had a million
subscribers it was like crazy [ __ ]
just took him to all the parties took
him all these things like people
couldn't help but to like put him in his
videos because it was so
next level what he was doing you know
like
we were talking about that yesterday was
that something you guys are going to
start to do is like
you know you guys are you were talking
yesterday kind of playing around with
the idea maybe doing a record label or
you know you guys do have the power to
blow up an artist and
you know i've seen it so like you feel
like you might be leaving money on the
table by not
doing more 100 i think that's like
the like that's why we're slowly
building like even a bigger team but
like
i say like so much people always rip on
me for that um sorry
the uh basically yeah like there's
there's so many fields i feel like that
we could be growing in
and it's and we're hitting as many as we
can but like
it does feel like right now like there
isn't enough hours in a day to like
really watch everything and monetize
every single category but like
it's it's getting there yeah it's crazy
what's the craziest purchase you've made
in the last five years like the craziest
just
[ __ ] like is it is it a watch is it
like what is the most
ignorant [ __ ] you've spent money on
probably the g
wagon the g wagon but i mean that's not
bad
that's kind of like zeroed out on that
and plus i'm i'm thinking i'm selling it
i've been driving this honda around and
dude it makes me happier to drive the
honda so i'm like i might just honestly
i just don't need it like
i want a house really bad i was looking
at houses in arizona up in flagstaff for
a bit but
i think i realized that i have to stay
in la for at least probably until i'm
30.
like i got some work to do here how do
you i'm 27
so a couple more years at least to like
really
get everything going yo interrupting
your podcast experience
to tell you about our sponsor odd socks
by the way man can we just talk about
how amazing oddsox is as a company not
only do they give you the most
comfortable socks
in the world um they also have like you
know they got ric flair socks
they got [ __ ] spongebob socks for the
children if you're in the oreos you know
shout out to all the fat [ __ ] out there
they got oreo socks they got pepsi socks
these are probably my favorites the
scarfaces
listen they got all kinds of [ __ ] going
on at odd socks not to mention
they just launched underwear they got
slippers they got masks
and on the most comfortable socks in the
world you gotta get the odd socks basics
and thank me later
go to oddssocks.com it's actually not
even on socks.com i should know it by
now
[ __ ] it's odd socksofficial.com
oddsoxofficial.comodsoxofficial.com
keywordbootleg kev and you'll save
twenty percent
off your final order
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kev
go to onsoxofficial.com and spend some
[ __ ] money and support the podcast
they're good people in the position that
you guys are in obviously that comes
with uh
tons of industry friends you know people
that that you meet like
who are some of the artists that have
really kind of embraced what you guys do
i've obviously seen you hanging out with
post and
and those guys um mgk you know but like
who are some of the artists that really
have kind of embraced the milk [ __ ]
um it's a hard one like
embraced us like yeah like you know like
i feel like
there's i've seen you guys with a lot of
like hanging out with a lot of different
artists
over the last few years is our content
we're like one of the only people not
like only but like there's not very many
people making content for people our age
so all the artists and the comedians and
the actors and like all these like
celebrities
like where i feel like we're like the
content that they watch so it's it made
it very easy for us to create
connections like
that's why we can hang out with like all
these rappers or [ __ ] anything
that means they like they're the ones
watching our [ __ ] yeah i think the first
night i met you guys was that uh
hitmaker's
not hit mega he was just here uh murder
beats
was a murder beats birthday yeah yeah it
was like a grammy party or something and
yeah
y w melly was there and i think we all
took a picture together
but uh but i think yeah i think that was
2017 might be eight might have been 18.
but i feel like that was what what year
did you guys move out here
like i think it was like 2015. oh [ __ ]
okay we were in downtown la for lots of
years lots of [ __ ] heroin smoke crack
smoke and
human feces in downtown l.a was it that
bad back then i've lived in all the
the worst places that's why i'm like now
trying to go down to like newport or
like the beach like
when you say the worst places explain
like i don't want to hate on anything
but
me personally i'm i'm a country guy
anyways but like
downtown wasn't my vibe now i've been in
the hills for a while it's like i mean
it's cool it's interesting but it's not
my vibe to live there and then
now we're in studio city but like i'm
really trying to get down to
like the california like live by the
water like that kind of like
just a chiller vibe like yeah
you guys are you you aren't you guys
moving headquarters down there yeah we
just uh we
might get approved on the 15th where
like a massive like 14 000 square foot
warehouse can be dope so with like you
you mentioned earlier working with
talent
for the for the content is there any
talent that you are
officially going to be working with for
for some of the content that you're
working on
yeah i don't know where we are on
contracts and what i can say
i don't know if that's a thing but i
don't know i don't know yeah we got a we
got a couple people in the works
yeah i think a big thing what's going
what's like kind of like motivated me to
push that too is um
right now with kovid say comedians for
an example they can't go
to do their shows they can't go to her
they can't do anything so what are they
all doing they're all doing
podcasts but now podcasts are super
saturated so
so many yeah now it's like we can we
could be like hey like we'll give you a
show it's gonna get mad views you're
gonna make some money
expose you to the whole another exactly
demographic perfect time to grow
something like that
uh when you guys do the six nine [ __ ]
it's crazy because nobody would
interview six nine
we we turned down interviewing him and i
feel like he really just came to la and
just tapped in with like the youtubers
yeah but i think you guys have like the
first thing that came out at least it
felt like it but like pretty big the
what was the uh
how did give us the back story on how 69
ended up doing it
did his team reach out to you guys or
how'd that go
i can't even remember what happened
there
i think it was
i think they reach out to us honestly i
can't even talk honestly i really don't
know
i can't remember but uh but they were
all honestly like they were
everyone was cool they were chill like
were you guys worried about any like
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] because you know he's
i was wearing mural for dinner like so
we were in new york
and you went to you went to dinner with
him in new york yeah
we filmed with him like a few times and
like i know like
so we go to this like rooftop and we're
all drinking and [ __ ] and uh
and like i was the only one that was
sober and like everyone was getting
pretty sloshed and then i was kind of
like
dude like we're just like on a [ __ ]
balcony like an open balcony
in new york in new york where he
snitched on everybody yeah when all the
shit's popping off and i don't follow
all that stuff so i don't really know i
just know
like a little bit but i was like a
little like [ __ ] like
people are posting stories like [ __ ] if
someone wants to do something right now
they probably could so i was definitely
sketching about it but
jeez i'll turn down fine so um with
[ __ ]
there's gonna be uh episode every week
every friday
yeah every friday and for a season i
mean i'm probably gonna do a 10 episode
season
and i don't know if like maybe take up
like take like uh
a week or two break to like keep
uploading and get ahead just because
i'm gonna need the time to actually work
on other projects and other like
original content so so you're pretty
much out on the prank [ __ ] though as far
as like
you know what's going on on the milk
channel it seems like you know
they're on the road all the time yeah i
think when it makes sense that's
what i've talked to kyle about is like
if it doesn't mean i have to like
leave for two weeks and like everything
starts hitting the fan back home with
the business like
whenever it just makes sense all and i
think something's really funny i'll come
be a part of it and
fly out outside of the business [ __ ]
whatever like i know you're a big
you got you showed me a tattoo of uh
what's the toronto blue jays
or what the [ __ ] is the guy on the on
your leg you got tattooed
oh maple leafs dude
the legend but i was going to say like
what
what like you know how do you spit i
mean you're obviously in the hockey
you said you're more into playing it
though not watching it right yeah i mean
but like what it would how do you spend
your time man when you're not [ __ ]
making millions of dollars
um drawing skating
[ __ ] honestly i got into tattooing
for a bit i do
like actually tattooing people yeah like
i got my own machine and
started doing the fake skin stuff
started tatting some people just little
bangers and um
i just got too busy with it but um i'm
definitely a hobbyist i like
i like i like just starting [ __ ] drawing
and tattooing
so is it was it hard to allow like get
someone to approve you tattooing their
body
no dude it was the opposite everybody
wanted one everyone was down yeah it was
more me being like nervous like i don't
want to [ __ ] this up
yeah and just like i i mean say like
people be all partying and [ __ ] and then
they'd be like oh tap me and i'd be like
because i know you can get like a real
bad name in that real quick if you're
like
super clean and professional and i
really wanted to be like professional
about it you were like
blood yeah so you were like really
trying to be a tattoo artist
uh no definitely not it's just a hobby
and
it's like anything in life you like try
it out and see if there's anything there
and uh
yeah and i just naturally started loving
it like it was fun
um what what your personal favorite
prank man that that that that
you you you got the most fun out of
because i feel like
there are some crazy ones i know like
the more recent one was when you're
wearing all white i was telling you i
love that character
yeah and i know these are always fun to
do i think i think that
the one i did on uh i was in beverly
hills or something and i was dressed
like some rich dude wearing a fur all
white for
and uh my chair broke and i like had a
big coffee cup go over me and [ __ ]
like those are always just fun to shoot
i love the clips that are like you don't
got to go shoot all day it's more like
just like you have this really funny
idea and you just go out and [ __ ]
do it you know i mean like you just get
that one shot and it's amazing like was
there ever anything that was so crazy so
extreme that you guys decided just not
to release it
i'm sure there is but i don't know it's
it's so on brand for us that yeah just
to drop the [ __ ] probably just dropped
it or like
yeah nothing comes to my mind damn
so what is next man
[ __ ] youtube shows is do you know
i watch both episodes dope show but
what's next like
obviously the content wing of things
yeah anything next for you though um
just keep doing what i'm doing growing
this [ __ ] i think
just like i said with the original
content elevating the brand
the cut and so the collabs
um there's like like you said the
the record label the like there's
there's so many avenues like you should
see my white boards at home they're just
[ __ ]
anything i'm surprised i haven't seen
like like is there a reason why i'm sure
you guys could easily have put your
stuff in like zoomies and [ __ ]
yeah though they've they've offered it
like you guys are trying to keep it
exclusive
yeah we i mean it doesn't make sense for
our brand i mean i think that that's
like
that's part of it right if someone ever
goes completely commercial or sells out
they'll like
do that and then whoever buys the
company would put it into distribution
like that but for us
our [ __ ] sells out like i don't really
want it to be sitting in stores and
i don't know if it would really sit in
zoomies really so maybe i don't know we
just always turned it down
but damn you didn't tell me earlier give
me you told me how many how many people
were on your side at once but give me
like what's
what's the bit the biggest clothing
check in a month you guys have cashed
i don't think i can say it it's a lot
yeah it's a lot of money the the thing
is though we're not
like we're definitely not balling it's
[ __ ]
we make a lot of money but like i mean
we have like 30 employees like
it's a [ __ ] business like there's a
lot of overhead
so much overhead and that's another
thing i've been looking into is just to
make us like
super profitable so we can i think right
now we're
um we're basically like funding like i
saying like the clothing line is funding
it's not going to get us rich it's it's
just funding all these big projects to
like get to that billion dollar
like icon that we want to get to your
dad's always with you
um i just met him yesterday he seems
like he's
just just turned up for his age oh yeah
it makes me so happy because like he's
such a doesn't leave his hometown kind
of guy
and uh and our bond's been dope like
i mean i've never been closer to my dad
than right now his name's pat right yeah
yeah so him and your mom obviously not
together
no so your dad is just kind of living
the dream
side by side with his boy yeah how long
ago did you bring him out here to la
um probably like
a year and a half two years ago like
really started having him out and then
uh
then we took him on a europe trip and
just like getting him to he would never
travel like that you know i mean
especially out of his own pocket so i
think uh
the fans loved him too so it was like i
know your dad's probably
grabbing so much like 23 year old
strange off being your dad it's crazy
he hasn't yet not yet no god bless him i
know
yeah yeah i feel like was there ever a
point in time because you know you guys
go to these [ __ ] college towns and
these areas and it's like it feels like
the parties are crazy like
give me a time where where [ __ ] maybe
got a little out of hand because i feel
like
you guys probably pull up to most of
these house parties and [ __ ] unwarranted
or do you guys kind of send someone in
to make sure it's cool because
you guys are being you guys are in the
thick of [ __ ] all the time
yeah i mean the whole la scene is very
you kind of just hang out with like
other lady dudes so it's pretty chill
but like yeah you just
start bouncing around party to party in
the hills and i
i mean like when you guys go to these
[ __ ] colleges and [ __ ] that
that [ __ ] is crazy yeah i don't even
find that shy
like even back in the day i didn't find
it too fun because it's just like
it's like a meet and greet while you're
trying to drink right because everyone's
everyone's trying to get [ __ ] up get
you [ __ ] up
like yeah that's crazy what is something
you've learned about
because you know you guys have you guys
had the mansion in the hills where it
seems like you guys
had a lot of people living there um we
always hear about like
la being especially now all the tick
tockers live here all the youtubers live
here
it's kind of a weird community like um
i i i feel like you guys don't embrace
that side of [ __ ]
as much as other people do which is dope
um
but just what have you learned about
coming out to la
and just like like it's just a weird
especially the way social media is
there's these [ __ ] tick-tock houses
and [ __ ] like
it's just like it's a weird world like
and you guys are kind of a part of that
world
yeah um what's some [ __ ] you've learned
from being in that environment for so
long
um i remember always having to like
stand with kyle a lot of people on the
team you always had to go back to canada
for a bit
and like reset because i i mean i used
to look at i don't really see it this
way as much anymore probably because of
covid but
it used to just be like it's just like a
it's like a video game out here like
you're just out here and you're just
[ __ ] with things and making money and
making moves and
everything feels very artificial and
it's like very true everything they say
in the movies and [ __ ] like
i i felt that way like i don't know if
it was half because i was sauced the
whole time but like
yeah i felt like a movie yeah it's like
it's like this little community
these [ __ ] yeah like yeah it's pretty
crazy
um cool man so uh the the youtube
channel is full send which is where your
show is now
at yeah there's gonna be a bunch of new
[ __ ] coming yeah when's your next
clothing drop
clothing drop is i'm pretty sure
february 23rd
yeah it's coming up damn yeah well [ __ ]
man you're killing it and i appreciate
the time
anything else you got you want to touch
on man um just that uh
the new season is out now um on elk
guys did a whole south america trip it's
[ __ ] yeah no i saw that [ __ ]
yeah what the what the [ __ ] what's his
name salim
yeah he ended up going to jail in
colombia i think we don't even know the
whole story yet so i got to talk to the
guys they literally just got home today
so that [ __ ] is wild
yeah like how did you guys find the
saleem kid because he he's
he's with all the shits yeah he was just
super funny online and
brought him in and i honestly think that
celine is super talented he's a
no he's a star for sure yeah and he has
like no limits yeah like that rafiki
[ __ ] did you see that yeah
that was like i remember he was on the
roof doing his leg [ __ ]
like whoa whoa whoa whoa what whatever
and i'm sitting there and i'm supposed
to be in character i'm [ __ ]
dying i have my head buried in my chest
and also i couldn't keep my [ __ ]
together
oh man who's who i wonder when you guys
did the zoom [ __ ] at the beginning of a
pandemic
was that like i mean that's kind of
low-hanging fruit like somebody should
like whose idea was that i don't know
who exactly the idea was
did like you guys have fans like hitting
you guys up like yeah people are sending
us codes and [ __ ] and um
it was perfect because we couldn't shoot
because of kobe when it was really
locked down
and these videos were getting like seven
million views so it was a
it just was perfect to do but uh it
definitely got to a point where like i
think they were cracking down on it
yeah look that the new episode just
dropped them in colombia which is
[ __ ] crazy
i feel like that's one of those things
you probably watching you're like i'm
glad i wasn't there yeah definitely
sometimes yeah for sure man we
appreciate you pulling up
and uh go check out the the youtube
channel
and um and look forward to all the all
the [ __ ] that's on the way man
hopefully we have another prank with
another artist that actually uh
yeah maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow boom
perfect thanks buddy okay bro